not that we needed more evidence to
question the mental stability of the
president but he spent his weekend
obviously at one of his golf resorts
this time the one in New Jersey spent
his weekend tweeting about various
conspiracies and of course about
Hillary's emails he's been president for
a year and a half and he's still
tweeting about Hillary's emails and it's
very quickly becoming like having
conspiracy theorists Alex Jones as
president of the United States Donald
Trump tweeting rife with the bizarre
grammar and capitalization that we've
become accustomed to over the weekend
quote the rigged witch-hunt originally
headed by FBI loverboy Peter S for one
year and now thirteen angry Democrats
should look into the missing DNC server
crooked Hillary's illegally deleted
emails the Pakistani fraudster uranium
one Podesta and so much more it's a
Democrat con job I don't know where to
start okay so let this is like under
fifty words I think I counted it's like
forty seven words here's what he has
squeezed into this small number of words
which is actually a sort of literary
achievement to squeeze this much
nonsense into only forty seven words he
calls the Russia investigation of
witch-hunt no evidence of that that's a
popular one of for Trump the Peter s
that he refers to as Peters Strock this
is the guy who was an FBI agent didn't
head the investigation he was one of
many people that were involved and once
his anti-trump text messages came to
light he was removed from the
investigation in fact the handling of
the Peter Strock situation was done 100%
correctly and has not yet not indicative
of any wrongdoing by the FBI Trump then
talks about thirteen angry Democrats
that's Trump claiming that thirteen
Democrats at the FBI run the entire
investigation which is core of course
not true and as you probably know Robert
Muller the guy in charge he's a lifelong
Republican Trump references a missing
DNC server there are missing records of
all kinds on both Democratic and
Republican sides not really a unique
thing we have a problem in our
government
with records going missing talks about
Hillary's emails Hillary lost almost two
years ago I don't know why he's still
talking about Hillary's emails he even
said that even though his priority was
going to be to lock her up that it's not
actually going to be so why he's talking
about it I don't know then he mentions
this Pakistani fraudster now that you
may not have heard about that refers to
an individual whose last name is a Wan
who's connected to a government IT
situation a Wan was a former IT aid for
Debbie wasserman-schultz and he made
unauthorized access to the servers of
the House of Representatives but again
it has nothing to do with the Trump
Russia investigation whatsoever he
brings up uranium one that's of course
the completely debunked conspiracy
theory that there's different versions
of it but one is Hillary illegally gave
all of our uranium to Russia and there's
actually even crazier versions of that
one even Shepard Smith on Fox News
debunked it and then he just says
Podesta that's not really anything
that's just referring to John John
Podesta as a person he refers to John
Podesta but that's that's not really
anything a single 47 word tweet with
eight distortions or straight-up
conspiracy theories well David the
president is busy he works something
like 20 hours a day he barely sleeps yes
you know ending the Korean War on Monday
and resuscitating the coal industry on
Tuesday he doesn't have time to
fact-check he doesn't have time to
spellcheck you're expecting too much
from him this is what happens when you
have an Alex Jones presidency or some
guy who watches Fox News in the Oval
Office and it's not how a stable genius
behaves and if you're Justin Trudeau or
Emmanuel macron or Angela Merkel Angela
Merkel what do you think when you see
this stuff and actually we know what
they think and we know that Trump
doesn't care what they think because
he's alienated them completely
what does Putin think when he sees this
stuff he thinks everything's going
exactly to plan and is very very pleased
today's program is made possible in part
by fruit or which is a social
forecasting game for your phone where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
go on the app find a future event you
feel confident enough about
make a prediction and make a bet on the
outcome that you think will happen using
the apps in-game fake currency if your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points you can compete with others
who are making their own prediction to
see who is the best forecaster there's
no real world money or cryptocurrency
involved the fun of futur is interacting
with others and showing the world your
skills at predicting the future will
Democrats take the White House house
this year will Trump run for re-election
will trump ever build the wall you can
go ahead and make your predictions show
off your forecasting skills and there
are also monthly competitions and prizes
for top forecasters and I'm on Foote or
you can wager on my predictions you can
also browse the politics category for
lots of interesting questions to go to
Foote or calm to sign up and make
forecast it's free it's on Android and
iOS as well as on web browsers and right
now on Foote or you can win cash prizes
for correct predictions about the World
Cup check it out at fut you you are calm